Stone surprise pour vous c'était
nécessaire bien écoutez c'est évident là
que quand on a vu les chiffres du PIB
canadien 3.1% qui c'est un accélération
puis au-delà des attentes quand on a vu
également l'inflation qui tout à coup
avait cessé de diminuer puis on voit
aussi surtout dans l'immobilier qui
normalement doit être réagir autour
d'intérêt qui est reparti à la hausse
que là les probabilités devenait très
élevé que la banque du scandale pas
encore compléter son travail et qu'on
est encore loin de la coupe au lait pour
revenir à une inflation de 2% au pays
c'est ça parce que la banque dit qu'elle
s'inquiète de voir l'inflation demeurer
coincer au-delà du 2% puis peut-être 3
et 4 %, qu'est-ce qui guette l'économie
si l'inflation ne revient pas 2% Clément
oui c'est ça puis les langages utilisés
Géral demeur coincé par des tenants mais
si jamais l'inflation ne collabore pas
puisqu'à demain élevé c'est à dire qu'en
extruments énergique on est autour de 3
et demi 4% ben pour retourner à 2%, il y
a pas 10 solutions c'est va falloir
créer un assez gros ralentissement
économique par d'autres hausse de taux
pour qui est tout à coup un nouvel
équilibre au niveau de l'offre la
demande et ça ça veut dire du chômage
plus élevé 1% et demi 2% plus élevé donc
ça ça veut dire une récession donc on
verra mais clairement si jamais les
ménages la consommation demeure très
très résilience et que les entreprises
continuent avec des augmentations de
précommandes on voit puis les
revendications salariales demeurent
élevée ben là on veut pas répéter
l'expérience des années 70 de laisser
l'inflation s'incruster donc on va avoir
d'autres hausse de taux et
malheureusement ça peut être signifié
Géral un attaillage brusque de
l'économie en 2024 bah oui et mais en
même temps j'ai le goût de vous demander
que les marginiaque si la banque n'est
pas un peu impatiente parce que l'effet
de ces hausses de taux ça ose de taux
rapide pendant un an l'effet va
commencer à se faire sentir le
prochainement puis pour les prochaines
années est-ce qu'elle est pas un peu
impatiente la Banque du Canada oui il
est vrai parce que il y a des délais de
transmission de 18 à 24 mois j'ai
commencé à se mettre en branle juste le
15 mois donc les impacts vont se faire
sentir surtout dans les prochains
trimestres comme vous savez environ le
tiers des emprunteurs podcasts qui ont
subi des hausses auto les autres avaient
pris des termes de 3 ans 5 ans et le 2/3
qui va renouveler d'un deux prochaines
années et comment rien ne mentionner
quand on parle de mensualité 1000
dollars de plus par mois ça c'est 12000
dollars par année avant impôts et net
d'impôt parce que c'est pas du tout
contrairement aux États-Unis donc oui la
Banque du Canada a décidé d'y aller plus
rapidement parce que l'histoire est
démontrée Gérald surtout dans les années
70 que si tu prends pas le patient avec
un médicament très fort dès le début ben
là tu as de la misère beaucoup plus par
la suite mais faut pas le tuer le
patient non plus
j'allais simplement ajouter que le
Bureau du surintendant des faillite note
une hausse des propositions de
consommateurs et qui fax parler des
soldes de cartes de crédit qui ont bondi
14 et demi pour cent au premier
trimestre par rapport à l'an dernier
est-ce que pas un danger de frapper trop
fort
il est évident parce que vous savez ceux
qui sont les plus affectés c'est les
jeunes ménages qui ont acheté une maison
un prélevé durant la pandémie à des taux
très très faibles puis jamais il y
aurait pensé que les taux d'intérêt
augmentèrent d'une façon aussi
importante par contre je reste quand
même optimiste puis il faut être nuancé
parce que les institutions financières
la dernière chose qu'ils veulent avoir
c'est la clé de la maison donc ils vont
faire preuve d'imagination peut-être
l'hypothèque on voulait aller sur 30 ou
35 ans d'amortissement on va être très
très conciliant pour que les gens
puissent conserver les maisons ce qui
est important c'est le marché du travail
aussi longtemps que l'emploi demeure
résilient on est capable d'absorber
c'est aux autos d’intérêt là pour
l'instant aussi l'économie américaine
est très vigoureuse et on se cachera pas
des migrations très fortes au pays ça
alimente la croissance économique mais
en même temps ça amène l'inflation puis
de la surchauffe dans le secteur
immobilier la forte immigration alimente
l'inflation ça disons que je vais
m'exprimer là pour être sûr que les gens
comprennent bien c'est que on a passé de
construction résidentielle pour
l'augmentation de population qu'on a
dans les 12 derniers mois la population
canadienne a augmenté 2 millions
d'habitants plus de la moitié c'est bien
de l'immigration et les mises enchantées
de la construction résidentielle au de
la misère à suivre pour faire face à
cette demande-là donc il y aura
peut-être des réflexions à y avoir mais
à moyen long terme évidemment
l'immigration contribue à création de
richesse et du PIB mais à court terme
c'est la conscience résidentielle ne
s'accélère pas pour finalement répondre
à la demande ça crée une pression ces
gens-là doivent se loger doivent se
manger et évidemment et contribuer à
croissance économique et là on a de la
misère avec une certaine surchauffe
qu'on voit de l'économie le 12 juillet
est-ce qu'une autre hausse est envisagée
moi oui c'est envisagé moi pour ma part
je pense qu'on va peut-être faire des
sauts moutons c'est à dire qu'on va
attendre on va voir l'économie au
deuxième trimestre on devrait avoir les
résultats juste au mois d'août début
septembre donc il se peut qu'on fasse
des pauses à l'occasion mais clairement
si jamais l'inflation de ce qu'on porte
pas comme la Banque du Canada satin et
que les entreprises visent augmenter des
prix davantage qu'attendus ou que les
revendications salariales sont trop
élevées et que les employeurs cèdent il
y aura d'autres hausses de taux Géral et
il y aura certainement pas de baisse de
taux avant le début de l'an prochain
Clément Gignac merci merci d'avoir été
avec nous c'est très clair au plaisir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]